second order optimization method thanks
a lot it's a delight to be back at
Berkeley so thanks a lot for the
invitation the organizers and organizing
this wonderful program food is
stochastic but some parts of the talk
that I want to talk about won't be
necessarily a stochastic is just that a
lot of these algorithms lend themselves
to be stochastic in some sense I'm gonna
take up pick up where Michael left off
yesterday and talk about a sort of an
alternative class of methods to what
Rachel talked about yesterday which
involve a bit more you know bits and
pieces and there are some there are many
more moving parts which are called
second order information you second
order optimization methods and if you
are wondering why they call it second or
they are the inferior to first order or
whatever just I will I will explain it
in details hopefully and when I was told
to you know put up put together slides
for this overview session I was sort of
conflicted what methods to include
because as you can imagine there is a
you know decades of research and these
sort of things and so you know it's hard
to pick and choose so I sort of settled
on methods that qualify on there one of
the three criterias that either I worked
on them or they were sort of semi
popular in machine learning so machine
learning people know them or at the
Machine people don't know them at all so
anything in between I removed
oh you mean no I'm don't know yeah yeah
well there is yes yes well I think how
could it be the last two are disjoint by
definition so yeah yeah but in anything
in between I sort of left out they may
work
that's true so actually I'm going to
point out I'm gonna point that to
exactly one of those methods all right
before I start at disclaimers obviously
you know I've only been given two hours
and so I need to be brief and for that a
lot of the results are just modified
rewarded and so on from the original
papers and also I won't be able to cover
even the methods that I I'm trying to
give an overview of I still leave out a
whole lot of related works and research
and interesting results okay so the
problem is an optimization problem so
you're given in the objective function
you want to minimize it over some kind
of it constraint said could be
unconstrained but doesn't matter at this
point and they're sort of a format of
the functions that we care about is
given as an expectation of another as an
expectation of a random function and the
the random variable we assume that is
you know following some sort of a
distribution which determines if you
know what's the likelihood of seeing
every one of these observations so the
likelihood of that is sort of governed
by this probability mission and I can
argue that a lot of the problems in
machine learning if not all of them but
definitely most of them can be written
in this format by just playing around
with this with this measure and the
function here just look at a generic I'm
not emphasizing on a particular type of
function it's just that machine learning
for example this F subsumes in it the
loss function as well as a prediction
function so it's a like a classification
you have a prediction function to give
labels to to a data and if you get it
wrong how much you have to pay so all
these things are incorporated inside
inside F and the whole average of this
of these functions essentially machine
learning is called risk everyone so this
the emphasis is really at this point is
that the rest
the talk I'm gonna sort of try to tackle
different metal or give an overview of
the methods that tackle solving this
problem on their certain assumptions
including convexity and non convexity
smoothness and also non smoothness so
it's a pretty broad sort of a class of
problems at this stage and another
emphasis is on them being high
dimensional so the parameter space that
we are trying to find our solution in
it's a high dimensional and most often
what we see and in fact an example of
the metric class of problems that you
saw in Richards talk yesterday they're
given when you were actually you have a
bunch of observations on hand you know
you're classifying a bunch of images is
an image debt and you are given a set of
images and that can be also cast as this
sort of a problem by just considering P
to be the the empirical or the
accounting measure over this least set
of observations but that I mean that
essentially the probability of any set
of set of data points is whether those
set of data points include is including
your training or not and if we do it
that way you end up getting the familiar
finite sum optimization minimization
problem or what's known in machine
learning as the empirical risk and
protocol for that because we are using
the empirical empirical measure as it's
an empirical approximation to the risk
another thing that that's important in
this whole series of especially methods
that I'm going to talk about is the data
be the problem being you know a big data
regime if you're in this framework if
you're solving an empirical risk
minimization you most likely have an end
to be large now this is in quotation
because a lot of people are actually
starting to hate using this term you
know it's going out of fashion its
loathed so I promise this is the last
time you hear me use the term big
and I will never say that one more time
and instead I'm gonna use the you know
humungous data instead of instead of a
big data
um alright so in the presence of
humongous data you know the optimization
with the literature goes back I don't
know how many years decades and
centuries pop potentially you you have a
lot of options but most of those options
actually don't fit this humongous data
regime because essentially the problem
with them is that they have very high
per iteration counts and the
modifications that people have been
trying to do over the last few few years
yeah well you know maybe decades is that
to turn these classical algorithms to be
more efficient by doing two things first
of all by turning every iteration to be
cheaper but at the same time try to
maintain the original convergence
properties that the the original method
enjoy to try to maintain that as much as
possible and you say you've seen that
you saw a little bit of that less
yesterday in Rachel's talk which within
the context the first order algorithms
but I really call it first order for
those who haven't seen these sort of
terminologies because they use first
order Taylor expansion if you will the
first order information and which
involves the gradient and that's why
they call them first or the information
now it's you know it's not a clear
definition but but just bear in mind
that if you only use in looking at the
gradient you can't call it the first
order and they go back you know the
example of it is great and descent goes
back to Cauchy which is you know we
compute the gradient every objective
function look at the direction opposite
to it and take a step along that now the
important point here that my coupon drug
yesterday is that here every component
of the object the the gradient is scaled
uniformly so every direction is equally
specially scaled for what it's worth
it's
because if you're dealing with the
smooth and weakly convex problem you end
up getting a rate 1 over K with
sublinear ray and if you have a smooth
or a strongly convex problem sorry I
mean yeah you end up getting linear rate
or geometric Ray and but the problem
with this that if you're dealing with
the humungous data and find that some
type problems just generating this or
evaluating this gradient is gonna be
very expensive because he's gonna scale
linearly with n and that's why you see
methods such as what Mitchell talked
about yesterday the stochastic gradient
descent mini-batch stuff which at every
iteration you end up getting a bunch of
realizations you choose among random and
you form this empirical approximation to
the true gradient we take a step along
the negative of that direction now it's
very cheap because if s is much smaller
than n then you end up having to
evaluate much fewer gradients but the
problem is that it's very slow and all
of a sudden becomes very slow if you
have a weakly convex smooth you went
from 1 over K to now 1 over square root
K that's a very painful rate if you have
never run this please do you'll see that
it's pretty much flat after K being 100
over around the 50 and if you have a
strongly convex problem you went from
linear convergence to sub linear so you
lose a quite a bit at the expense of
being per iteration cheaper convergence
rate for example the objective value
goes down to the optimal the differences
between the objective value and the
optimal that so you can have for example
say the objective value at this current
iteration relic you know the difference
of that with the true objective with the
true minimizer or sorry D the optimal
value goes down with the rate 1 over K
for example you'll see a couple of those
things later on
okay I'll talk to I'm not going to get
into Epsilon right now but we'll talk
about because epsilon brings out another
opens up a can of worms
all right so what people do they modify
these SGD type algorithms to do two
things first of all achieve the full
convergence so the convergence rate of
the full gradient descent but at the
same time preserve the per iteration
cost of SGD and you see a whole lot of
class of methods that do just that
second-order methods however they are
called second-order not because
necessarily they're inferior or they
have to be the second in line they just
used a second order information right in
addition to the gradient they also look
at the curvature or the Hessian
information and goes back to Newton that
you used this sort of methods to solve
the roots of a cubic polynomial and very
similar to gradient descent you compute
the direction of the gradient you take
the negative of that direction but
before scaling the components of the
resulting vector you actually transform
the gradient through the application of
the inverse of the Hessian now what it
does it not uniformly scales every
component of F what does that mean that
means that the directions that are
sorted towards the shallow regions or
the live regions with low curvature are
actually getting magnified and the
directions that are pointing towards the
steep or the very high curvature regions
they are getting less emphasized and as
a result if you have something that
you've seen in many textbooks that you
have a a level set of a quadratic which
is pretty ill-conditioned and you see
this sort of elongated picture and if
you start from here if you have any
gradient descent you see you end up
getting zigzagging around because you're
pretty much always pointing in that
direction
whereas when you apply the inverse
subject they the hash
and you say okay this is the direction
along the shallow or the flat regions
that region that direction is going to
get magnified this direction is going to
get less it's going to get less
emphasized then you end up going along
that direction in fact in this case you
end up converging is just one iteration
yes but I wrote it that's a good thing
you meant reminded me of I wrote it this
way but that doesn't mean it's going to
be computed this way this is just I've
wrote it that you apply the inverse but
that's not how we do it and I'm going to
talk about how we do it alright so non
uniformly scale gradient the problem is
actually quite fast you know you have
the locally super linear convergence
rate and if you're a strong convexity
locally quadratic globally also linear
here also we can show recently that this
is also globally linear as well but the
progression costs pretty high even if
you don't form this matrix I wanna
invert it at the end of the day you have
to deal with some kind of a matrix at
some point as a result per iteration
cost aside and what I'm going to be
talking about I'm going to talking about
the methods that try to alleviate this
problem but at the same time sort of try
to maintain these rates now they might
not be able to question
[Music]
hey just for example Oh super linear
that means it's so so if you look at the
iteration and this being the true true
solution if you look at the ratio of
this and
this is you so the numerator actually
ends up going faster and faster and
faster
alright so I've divided my talking to
two pieces the first part is the the
first session and then the second
session part 1 I'm going to focus only
on convex problems for smooth case
pretty much I can say there is not much
many competition beyond Newton CG and
I'm going to talk about that various
aspect of it and there's also a non
smooth case Newton type methods are only
known to be useful or these people think
that they can be applicable only for
smooth problems and that's not
necessarily true you can actually apply
similar techniques to completely non
smooth problems I'm going to talk about
two classes of such methods one is the
proximal Newton method and the other one
is a semi smooth in the context of semi
smooth optimization the second part I
will talk about non convexity I've
divide that into two classes of
algorithms one of the line search based
methods and among which I will focus on
the BFGS l-bfgs type stuff the gauss
newton probably less known in machine
learning heavily used in scientific
computing and natural gradient which is
heavily used in machine learning less
known scientific computing and you can
argue that for example BFGS could have
very well been up here but I put it down
here because you can apply it in non
convex problems without really thinking
twice and second one is a trust region
based methods which the examples are
trust region and also cubic
regularization you might say this is not
really a trust region but you can argue
that it sort of mimics what trust region
try to do that's why I put it over here
so and finally I got time some
discussions and examples actually
definitely discussions but might not be
examples all right so let's look at
Newton C G and let's just focus on the
empirical risk minimization or the
finite sum problem you go to some a
bunch of functions and the emphasis is
that for now either every one of these
summonses convex and smooth and also n
is large I also think that for now
overall the
function the the objective function is
strongly convex which implies that you
have a unique minimize and D as I
mentioned before or large okay so how do
we go about generating or coming up with
algorithms one way of doing this sort of
thing generating iterative schemes are
by looking at its what's known as sort
of a local search what does that mean
that means that at every point suppose
I'm a point XK and I want to minimize
this this function f minimize our being
here so at every point I form some kind
of an approximation local approximation
to the function here it's shown a
quadratic approximation doesn't have to
be but I find that approximation which
is easier to work with
I find the minimizer of that approximate
function and take that as my next
iterate hopefully it's going to be
closer to my true solution I keep you
doing like this and this is sort of
given in a quadratic form because this
is a linear term and this is a quadratic
term but doesn't have to be this way you
can write it many different ways and
depending on what you put in here and
here you are not getting different
methods so for example if I put the full
gradient here and put the full Hessian
here I'm not getting newton method if I
instead replace relation with identity I
get the gradient descent or projected
gradient descent and if I actually
remove this quadratic altogether I end
up getting Frank Wolff V or conditional
conditional gradient I think that's
what's called in some communities which
is again popular method machine learning
mini-batch stds but replacing this to be
the sample average of the gradient and
HTP identity what I'm going to be
talking about are two method a new class
of methods we call sub sample mutant
methods where you either use a full
gradient here and sub sample the Haitian
meaning that you sample a subset of
these indices form the empirical average
only using those samples and replaced
considered as an approximation to your
Hessian the second one is the one that
actually you sampled both so not only
you sample the hessian but also you
sample
their gradient and you can sample them
independently or simultaneously and so
on and so forth all right so for now
let's look at unconstrained problem just
to make things easier most of these
results go through almost seamlessly
when you put in the constraint in the
sub-problem okay in there in the
unconstraint the iterations turn out to
be like this so you still have a
quadratic you find the direction that
minimizes this this quadratic and you
find that direction you take a step
along that direction right and in here
I'm gonna be for now putting the full
gradient here I'm gonna put this sub
sample tation over here so that will be
my iterative scheme now first let's talk
about global convergence much Michael
mentioned a little bit yesterday about
local and global what that means is that
global convergence is that I want to
start my algorithm I couldn't care less
how I started
anywhere I started I want to get to my
solution and that's what we're gonna
talk about for now okay so there are two
components in this iterative scheme
right one is the direction the other one
is these step size so let's talk about
how we're gonna do those in this
framework and that would probably answer
that question about the matrix Amer's so
in order to compute the direction if you
look at this quadratic again because
it's unconstrained the solution of this
if you can realize you realize that I
put an approximation here because
because it's sort of unreasonable and
also very expensive to assume that we
can find the exact solution of this I'll
talk about this but the exact solution
of this is the solution of a linear
system involved in H and minus G which
is gonna be this linear system if this
was an equality the solution of this
system because I assume strong convexity
as long as this H is also strongly what
you could positive definite then the
solution of that quadratic balls down
the solution of this linear system and I
would like to find that P and once I
have that P I need to find my step size
well one of the famous ones that works
beautifully in this scenario is what's
known as the
micoline search which what we do we say
okay we have a direction we want to find
the step size how long should I go along
that direction
give me an alpha such that if I go along
that direction by that much I end up
being smaller that where I started but
also a little bit even not only just be
smaller but also be smaller by a by a
wise signify by an amount which is
determined by this linear approximation
if you will of the function and this
this term has to be obviously negative
right if it's positive then this doesn't
make any sense it has to be negative
because if this term is negative then if
I have a good step size then I know at
least that my objective value is gonna
improve compared to where I started and
once I have these two I take a step
along those right okay so and then I can
put everything in the simple algorithm
compute the full gradient sample from
the set of indices I'll talk about how
but for now suppose you know how go get
those samples of indices compute the
approximation of the Hessian only using
these samples solve this linear system
again I'm going to talk about how but
solve this linear system approximately
find the P put the P back inside this
try to find an alpha that satisfies this
and you that's what it's done usually
it's done approximately using the
backtracking line search I try an alpha
here most often one and I try to cut it
back and make it smaller and smaller and
smaller until this inequality satisfied
I take that step so find that step I
have two components r1 and I take a step
along that direction
can you guarantee the lionsearch
produces yes I'll talk about so the very
first after say a seminal paper really
that sort of opened up research in the
direction of sampling the Hessian was
this paper that well people before that
had done it but nobody has actually
tried to do any theory in this in this
line and this was the first first work
that I know that did that and they
assumed that every one of the components
function remember the function is a sum
of these if
and they assume that every one of these
defies is strongly convex by that I mean
that the curvature is never zero every
direction you look at you can put a
quadratic underneath it it's twice
differentiable a blah blah blah but if
you do that and if you go through this
algorithm you end up getting that at the
limit the gradient is 0 so you converge
to the stationary point the problem is
convex that's your solution you're done
but the problem was that the rate there
is no rate and the issue is is
everything is asymptotic right you have
to wait infinite amount of time before
you actually can say something about
your solution so as a result people
would like in machine learning more to
have rates as opposed to asymptotic
results which was a classical goal of
optimization you just wanted asymptotic
results these days machine learning in
particular they won't just rate I want
to know how fast my objective is
improving and the question earlier on
that what do I mean by rate for example
is it statements such as this that if I
compare how far I am right now compared
to the optimal solution compare that
with how far away I was when I started
how smaller am I now and how that and
this difference how fast is it improving
at every iteration and this rate of
improvement is called the convergence
rate so this paper showed that again
under the same a set of assumptions if I
do random uniform sampling of the
Hessian in expectation I end up getting
this decreasing objective value and the
rate being this and this cap I is the
same as what Rachel talked about
yesterday the condition number in
quotations because there's a whole note
you know different ways of defining what
condition number is but the problem is
that the assumption was that F is only
the F is strongly compact it's a little
bit too you know strong of an assumption
what if the or the overall F is strongly
convex but each individual ones there
are only weakly convex and you might
wonder hey is there any possibility of
having a problem such as this and indeed
it is true suppose you have something
such as you know machine learning a lot
of problems can be written
this way so you have a loss of this of
this of this form and suppose also my
data did this a is are given so these
are like the data points or the images
if you will and suppose there are in R D
and if I put them in a as rows of this n
by D matrix this matrix is full column
rank and if that's true so the matrix is
full rank and every one of these loss
functions remember this is a loss
functions from R to R every one of them
is strongly convex then the component
function now that the function as a
function of big X so this whole thing if
I took look at the Hessians actually a
Rank 1 matrix
so it's not only a strongly convex far
from being a strongly complex problem
each one of them you have you know D
minus one direction of completely
nothing and but if you add them together
you can show that the Hessian of the
full function ends up being in fact
uniformly bounded away from 0 so that
overall problem is actually strongly
convex even though each one of these
individual function is only weakly
convex and this is where we sort of
started to look at this problem and we
said ok so suppose we sample like this
what are the conditions that we need in
order to only assume these sort of
conditions and we stick and run through
our algorithm and it's very simple
argument actually not difficult at all
to show that if you have Hessian you
have a strongly convex problem and each
individual functions are only convex and
also smooth in the case in the context
of you know the differences between the
gradient is not going to explode crazy
then you know you have you can have
these epsilon-delta arguments that if
your sample size is large enough and
large by that depends on this epsilon
depends on Delta depends on dimension as
well as this condition number Kappa if
you sample this many times you can
guarantee with this high probability
that you're gonna be you know always
uniformly bounded away from 0 so this
sample tation up here it's going to
always be paused
definite even though individual sample
functions are just weakly convex the
overall sample function stays positive
death strongly convex with this with
this parameter okay so now we know how
to form our age so now let's see how we
can get our P so that was this
approximate solution to this linear
system I just showed you that if I do it
this way the Haitian remains positive
definite so I have a positive definite
linear system and I want it to be
approximate how do i define approximate
solution by looking at the residuals
right so the residual of this problem is
how much left hand side differs from the
right hand side so left hand side - -
right inside so that's why the - now is
a + relative to some relative error
which is here given by this some
fraction of for example if I put 0 in
here right and I put using CG can
someone tell me why just specifically
mentioned CG and the answer is not it
depends actually has it what why did I
put CG that's the first natural answer
that that obvious you know people know
these things will give and that's very
true H is positive dammit definite
symmetric positive definite but that's
not all all the reasons why we use it
because it's symmetric and I can I can I
might as well use mean risk for example
in fact there are papers bamako I sure
that mean R is in certain situations
actually much better than CG because
mean rays you look actually minimizing
the residual of the linear system and
that's what we are monitoring anyways so
you might as well use main rent so the
problem is you know maybe the answer is
it depends because it depends if I'm
thinking about it theoretically or
practically theoretically speaking
I can technically use Minter's as well
but so practically but theoretically
when I you see G what I'm doing
implicitly at
reiteration of CG I'm minimizing this
quadratic subject to some subspace of T
dimensions we call it a crowd of
subspace with teeth order crown subspace
for the teeth iteration so if I do CG in
teeth iteration I stop that that vector
I get is the exact solution of this
problem
it's a subspace among all the vectors
also contains zero so I can put zero in
here so that means that this PT whatever
it does it's going to give me an
objective value that's better than zero
so that means this if I plug back in
here it's always non-negative and that
if I rearrange terms that means my
direction of descent is the direction
that I get it's always gonna be
direction of descent because this is a
positive definite so this quadratic is
always positive there's a negative so
this right-hand side is always negative
as a result the direction that I get
always going to be direction of descent
and that's what we want as part of a
line suggest
so the possible that these that if use
these other techniques you could also
prove something rages so I talked with
Michael yesterday if there is any
solution he would know it but he I'm not
sure if there is one no wonder that
Manson that men race might be good even
my nature said definite sure ban and
thus did let's trust raids on the
problem yeah so so it might be you know
easier to look at minerals for trust
region to problems but for Newton Newton
type because we emphasize on the
direction of descent might be harder
theoretically but practically I am also
with the same opinion as Michael that
minerals probably is a much better thing
than that CG for the fact that we
terminate CG by looking at residuals
anyway so you might as well do something
that minimizes the residuals anyways
these were some interesting things that
that came up a little while ago when I
was thinking about these things all
right so the result is this if I have
this this tolerance the relative
residual so in MATLAB you put in your
function handle H you give it the right
hand side and you also put it the top
relative tolerance right three
parameters and what are the three
parameters is the relative tolerance and
we showed in this paper that if you
relative tolerance is only in the order
of 1 over a square root of the condition
number you see the condition number is
large for thank goodness this is at
least 1 over square root of the
condition number if you do it that way
then we talk about what you end up
getting rate which is very close to the
rate of the exact full Newton method -
this little 1 plus 1 minus epsilon
approximation all right now let me turn
to local converges what's local this is
almost global right so I start from
arbitrary point in the space I want to
get to my solution local convergence is
that let's suppose I'm close enough to
date to the to the optimal solution and
that's what the classical analysis of
Newton's method sort of focused on is
still even today a lot of papers come
out that focus purely on on local
converges they want to
see how that behaves because a lot of
communities they care about hot
Precision's and that's where these local
converges come out machine learning not
so much so maybe local coverage is not
as interesting but not everything should
be driven by machine learning so let's
just talk about this in local converges
if you'd sort of sample the same way and
you run through the auger and the the
argument you see that if you're close
enough to the solution you end up
getting an error recursion so at the
next iteration compared to the current
iteration you get an error recursion
which got a linear term here and also
has a quadratic term and it's famously
known as a linear quadratic error
recursion and pretty much doesn't matter
how you approximate your matrix it just
almost always it boils down to being a
similar sort of setup for example the
very first paper that looked at this
subsample mutant is in the local regime
regime was was this paper which they
said okay a subsample my hessian then i
do this truncated SVD for some reasons
that the mission in this paper i don't
necessarily agree with those reasons but
they do it and you know they say that
now we have the truncation then we can
pretty much implicitly form the inverse
let's suppose we do that and now we take
a Newton step and then be projected on
to the constraint and now we we go that
way and they showed that if you do it
that way
locally remember all these results are
local they're not global you have to
ensure that your initial iterate is
close enough locally you end up getting
these quadratus a linear quadratic
things which these with these constants
the first constant linear term depends
on the accuracy of your approximation
through the size of the sample second
term is sort of unrelated in some way
and it only depends on some parameters
corresponding to the problem right and
that's the theme that happens all the
time but there's I mean even though they
wrote it this way I just want to make a
word of caution of using this type if
you have a constrained optimization and
you do it taking newton's
and then project onto this is known as
the two metric gradient projection one
metric because we are using the Hessian
to scale the gradient and the other one
because we're sort of projecting on
without with the orthogonal projection
so it's two metric it's known to have
issues that you know starting from an
arbitrary point this algorithm actually
might not converge so this is not the
way we do constrain optimization with
Newton however there are classes of
algorithms classes a problem such as for
example the bound constraints box
constraints and those sort of things
where you can't do these things but
arbitrary constraints you can't really
take either a shoes like this locally it
works but globally you might end up
having issues and so we also did similar
works and he said okay so suppose we're
doing sampling as before if you sample
this many times your subs amputation
will preserve the curvature or the
spectrum of the original Hessian to
within epsilon this signs is just sort
of like a the partial ordering of the
make between minute symmetric matrices
and if we do that we end up getting
exact same sort of linear quadratic
recursion but they take the cool thing
about the the thing that we got was that
the linear term depends only on the
epsilon yep idea accuracy of the
approximation the condition number as
well as the inexactness of the linear
system soft right the second term
doesn't depend almost on anything except
through that which you can also ignore
this term altogether so what does that
mean that means that if I get rid of
this term then the linear rate of the
determinate multiplies the linear term
can be problem independent right it
depends on epsilon which are prescribed
and that turns out to be the case if I
set my theta to be of this order so
again 1 over square root of Kappa to
solve my linear system so when you put
into MATLAB put 1 over square root of
Kappa then this coefficient becomes
problem independent now when we are
close enough to the solution such that
this term is dominant dominating this
term
I can ignore that one now we end up
getting a rate that's completely problem
independent and that's what we see in
practice as well and I'm going to
hopefully show some some result as well
as the theoretical results that you can
prescribe the rate of convergence this
is sort of funny but that's what happens
you can prescribe the rate of
convergence and you do things right at
some point you end up getting that rate
of convergence okay so it's completely
problem independent this is a property
of Newton method no other method has
this they store the problem okay now and
putting all together you know local plus
global if you start from an arbitrary
point you have all the way linear
convergence after certain number of
iterations you turn into this problem
independent linear rate and finally and
most interestingly actually to me is
that after certain number of iterations
you don't need to do line search anymore
step sides of one and one is a magical
number it's the natural step size of the
full Newton method in fact when you do
second-order Taylor expansion that's why
there is no alpha there right it's just
one it's accepted for all the subsequent
iterations and this is cool because one
of the heroes of mine professor no civil
actually says any optimization algorithm
for which the unit's mm worse has some
wisdom in it and it's too much of a
fluke if the unit step length
accidentally works in fact Michael and I
and also Jorge we all sort of want to
define second-order methods that the
methods that can run with step size of
one that's at some certain asymptotic
regime okay so let me just push ahead
and talk a little bit about this
exploiting structure and then move on to
non smoothness so suppose the problem is
given as the an example that I gave last
time so support vector machine or
whatever a smooth version of it right
then it's very straightforward to see
that the Hessian of this this function
you can write it as an some matrix
transpose a diagonal matrix times the
matrix itself where a is an N by D so n
is the number of data points D
the dimension of X you get an end by the
matrix where the rows of this matrix are
these data points and D is a diagonal
matrix matrix whose diagonal elements
are the second order derivative of l
ellie's from our to our second order
derivative evaluated at these at these
points ok that is a lot of a structure
in it and it turns out that if you have
problems like this you can do stuff that
are bit more smarter than just arbitrary
uniform sampling that we saw so much bad
things about over the last couple days
rightfully so
so the first work that actually looked
at problems of this work is the plan
Sheehan went right from here that they
said all right so we have this quadratic
problem that I have to form and solve at
every iteration but suppose my Hessian
is given in a some sort of a what they
call a square root factorization right
I'm giving it my matrix B such that B
transpose B give me that now this B is
different than the be from a chollas key
factorization if you will which I if I
had that one then I didn't have to do
any of this stuff right it's just simple
to solve this base is a tall matrix so I
can't solve a linear system knowing this
factorization it's a tall matrix suppose
I'm given like that then can I use
anything to speed things up and we saw a
lot of that yesterday right so if I put
this F as B transpose B this ends up
being the norm of this vector multiplied
by B ice we saw a whole lot of stuff to
do yesterday this is n by D how we can
sketch this be such that we reduce this
from n by D to be something smaller
right so what we do we stick is
sketching matrix or sampling matrix in
between hopefully that matrix is gonna
be it's gonna be short and fat but it's
gonna be less fat than bees tall and if
that's case then s times V will be
roughly squared and of the dimension
smaller than n so hopefully I can work
with that much easier and end up getting
a soft problem that's much easier to
solve I mean so many examples of these
yesterday so if I go from n by D to sy d
hopefully s
small name none of us are problems is
easier I'm not gonna bother you with it
you know sub Gaussian randomized Hanuma
non-uniform and sparse transforms and so
on you can use anything you want really
it's independent of the of what you use
however the guarantees that you get at
the end in terms of the iteration
complexities as well as the running time
will depend on the sketching that you
use but it's a you know we studied a lot
of this over the last couple of days
an example is a non-uniform sampling
that we showed in this paper if you do
through random sampling again this we
had yesterday and leverage score
sampling we ended up getting rates that
have some advantages over say uniform
sampling or other kinds of sampling I'm
gonna bore you with it there is another
celina work that says forget about the
Hessian itself what I care about is the
inverse of the Hessian so I would like
to have a sketch or an approximation to
the inverse of dashing that's a tough
problem you can't really have an
unbiased estimator of the inverse
inverse of the matrix but these guys say
well you know we're gonna make something
and do make you work so use the
anointment series or Taylor expansion of
a inverse as long as this is positive
definite and bounded by one this this
you can get rid of and as long as you
have this knowing once you use expansion
well all I need to do I just need to
truncate it right if I truncate it at
some part J then hopefully what I end up
getting is a good approximation to my
inverse and it's nice thing about it is
that you can write it as this recursive
that the J depends on J minus 1 through
a recursive problem the recursive
equation the issue is that you have a
full n here so I haven't done much yet
so might as well put a subsampling here
as well so technically speaking they
said we want you know approximate the
inverse but they needed the
approximation of the the the Hessian at
the same time so but anyways it's a neat
idea and if you do it that way you end
up getting a three loop recursion three
rupa net three nested loop one is do
overall optimization and two of them
just to be able to evaluate this thing
times a vector and you end up getting
this actually lends itself very nicely
to problems such as GLM's
so now we have that in our paper nips a
couple years ago where we compared all
these all these methods including the
last one nice you mention and all
different samplings and so on so I put
that four we heard a couple of times
archival purposes that we can sort of
refer back to later okay so I'm not
going to talk about the convergence of
the gradient because I'm running out of
time for this one so let me just it's
similar very similar to the case where
you have the full gradient it's just the
difference is that if you sample the
gradient then you can only show that you
converge to a neighborhood around the
solution governed by the approximation
error that you have you through gradient
and you have to come up with ways to
drive this this sort of iterations all
the way to the true solution but not too
interesting really oh no I didn't say
anything but yeah it's very close to
sorry I didn't put it there
it wasn't my work actually it's someone
else's word but they have two set of set
of samples or if you will one is this
sample of approximating a and the other
one is the how what's the truncation and
both of them is sort of a probabilistic
type analysis I don't remember off the
top of my head two samples but your
sampling and then you doing this
recursively you have dependencies you're
using fresh samples so I think they
rearranged it in a smart way such that I
think you yes so I think three nested
loop at every direction of the inner
loop you sort of draw new samples if I
can remember correctly I don't know so
let me know I'm on the record so let me
not say something I don't I don't
remember all right so the non-smooth
right if you ask someone in the street
that can you run Newton method they say
well even on smooth problems people say
you captain inverse the matrix which we
saw we should do it so I save him for
that you don't use it but then let me
say it's a non smooth problem everywhere
like just get out of here you definitely
can't use second order information and
it turns out that no there is a whole
lot of stuff that you can do and lend
themselves with some beautiful
theoretical results okay
the first of all I'm gonna talk it so
let's let's set up the problem it's a
sum of two functions or only had one
last time let's add another one which is
gonna add this non smoothness to my
problem now for now let's assume F is
smooth and R is non smooth right I'm
gonna relax this in a few slides but
suppose you have a smooth plus and non
smooth component this think of an l1
regularization or nucleo no memorization
all these famous stuff that people do
mission right okay one thing that you
can do is the approach that these guys
did and what they said they said hey we
wanted to form a quadratic saw problem
if we had a smooth problem I could have
just done simply just a Newton type
stuff put the gradient over here a shell
over here or approximation of each
either one of them form a quadratic can
go about that way I don't know I'm not
smooth so I don't have a gradient but
lucky I'm I'm convex so I have what's
known as sub gradient right so you
collect it's or sub differential is a
collection of vectors that behave log
gradient in a certain sense so I'm going
to form instead of this limit this
quadratic approximation I do what they
call it quasi quadratic or non quadratic
sub problem which I find the vector from
this set of sub differentials so I
consider F and are don't look at one of
them be smooth the other one non
smoother just treat them both the same
and compute the sub gradient of this get
the supremum for every P and then find
what P gives me the minimum right it's
not quadratic but it is nice and this H
obviously we can't take the second order
but if that easy here but what we end up
doing we so for example put at BFGS type
matrix over there the point being is
that there is a whole lot of quadratics
that I can put in here give it every one
of these vectors in this but if I find
if I actually plot this I end up getting
something this bald red that's not
quadratic anymore you see this it's not
as quadratic but he approximate this in
some ways you can say better at least
around the kink over here the problem is
that this is a steepest descent type
stuff and it's known that when you are
non smooth the steepest direction of
steepest
cent which we use the subgradient to
find that but it's just not going to
converge at times and that's why they
have a whole lot of stuff around this
algorithm to make sure that this
converges another line of work is the
one that actually Michael Saunders
initiated a couple years ago as well as
that some other guys he said I have a
smooth plus non smooth I might as well
use this structure and come up with my
durations my F is smooth so let me put
the the gradient of F over there my R is
not smooth let me just let it be as is
so I have the linearization of the first
term leave the second term as is or the
0th order expansion of it if you will
and then add the quadratic now I still
have some quarter the quadratic plus a
non smooth term but this is much easier
right hopefully this is going to be much
easier to solve because doesn't involve
F and as long as I can solve this
problem and this is an easy problem such
as l1 or whatever this is easy to do
examples of this I'm not going to talk
about let's see it just ignore the math
for you ignored no like you don't you
put it there but you don't do any
approximation for your dad limits hang
on well it is not really because it
involves P still right so it still
involves P but I'm not doing anything
with it I'm looking at it just as it
like it okay so this saw prop this is my
saw problem right so I have a quadratic
plus this non smooth term and I can
obviously solve this exactly this is
gonna be impossible I need to do it in
approximately approximately how do we do
this or the things you can show very
easy that your TP that's the optimal
solution of this is gonna be a P that's
gonna be the solution of this fixed
point from fixed point system whereas
this procs you must approach procs
over and over again when the compressive
sensing was just booming a few years ago
the procs was all over the place because
of the L want ER and I still is and so
this is the solution what is aprox is a
sub problem of this kind so the
linearization of this quadratic term
right here I turn it linear be quadratic
leave that again as is and
regularization over here it looks a
little bit magical but it is it's it's
you know it's got a whole host of theory
behind it and if I can find the P that
satisfies this essentially plug P in
here and that's the optimal solution I
know that this will be this optimal
solution of of that of that sub problem
up there
well approximation of that now you can
translate it to the approximation of
this fixed point iteration and you say I
want to find a P that's okay it's not
exactly like that but it's going to be
close at least it's gonna be better than
if I plug in zero right if I plug in
zero in here whatever I get I should do
better than that and I put it over here
and that would be my in exactness
criteria and some additional decrease
conditions that they're not really
they're not the pretty much trivial
stuff to add just to make sure the
converges go through okay then you do
this step size through it particular
line search and you end up getting
results that is you know super linear
convergence certain cases it's the
quadratic and and so on a sofa so
behaves very much like newton method
okay now let me go to the in the last
five minutes or ten minutes let me talk
about semi smooth because this is
actually probably a lot more heavy-duty
when it comes to doing theory
theoretical stuff than the proximal
table numbers okay so here I assume that
I have a function f let's suppose it's
you know you know doesn't have to be
convex or or anything but let's suppose
it's comebacks but it could be non
smooth right so I'm not really assuming
anything now it's just really F could be
arbitrary pretty much and and are I
still want it to be convex and could
denouncements right so this problem is
significantly more challenging
challenging that anything I put on the
slides before all right now remember
from this few slides they go the
proximal Newton algorithms the ad saw
problems of this kind right I can
rewrite this to be s again another procs
sort of an iteration type so this will
exactly be
that as long as I define my products to
be this so now if you have seen trucks
before products you know of this
function are you've seen it without
disturbing hear most often you've seen
the Euclidean term but here it's it's
sort of a mile an obese if you will of
distance as measured by this matrix H
and this H remember back then was an
approximation to the Hessian okay so as
long as I can define my problems like
this this is now yes no I'm not as no I
said no no no I said suppose if the
proximal Newton method right
we had suppose this edge could be
anything I'm not saying this is a
Haitian could be so I'll be traumatic as
long as positive definite this sort of
iteration can be written as this sort of
a proximal point iterations okay no no
no not yet H is an arbitrary gradient
was the gradient but H could be anything
as long as it's positive definite and I
end up getting that the idea that just
get the idea across the idea of
semi-smooth is this so we could remember
this remember this iterations
let's now look at Newton for smooth
problems Newton was motivated for
solving nonlinear problems nonlinear
route finding secession when R is smooth
how do we do that we compute the
Jacobian of R and we do two issues of
this kind which in the case of the
optimization our function is the our
nonlinear system is the gradient if you
will we end up getting history and times
something equals minus degraded right
and then we do two issues like that the
idea for semi-smooth optimization is
that let me write down the okay so forth
for the semi-smooth if you want to solve
this and this is semi smooth you replace
this Jacobian Ravager cobia more what's
known as the generalized or clark's
generalized Jacobian I'm going to talk a
little bit about those things and which
exists most often even when what not
most often but it exists when the the
truth Jacobian doesn't exist and if I
can do it that way I can pretty much run
through the same type of algorithm now
what would be my nonlinear system that I
care about here I don't have a gradient
right this non smooth I don't have a
gradient and greater than equals zero
doesn't mean anything
but what is my nonlinear system my
nonlinear system is actually something
like this which you can easily show that
this being zero is a stationary point
amounts to a stationary point of your
original problem that if you have an X
that the stationary point of the
original problem this would be zero well
then my task is to find the zero of this
function but this function involves this
crazy products operation which is most
often semi smooth and then you have to
do semi-smooth newton method quickly
tell you run through these these at
least get the terminology across is that
what is a clocks general logic who
everybody knows the Jacobian so what is
it clerks general Jacoby suppose I have
a function that's locally Lipschitz
continuous right you have this beautiful
result that says if you have a
delicious local eateries continuously
say almost everybody visual it's not
everybody vegetable but it's almost
everywhere differentiable so supposed to
collect all the points that this
function is differentiable on I put it
is set called dr and concert' the
sequence of all these points every one
of them is different function is
differentiable at those points and I can
compute the Jacobian there right so I
send these points to a limit and I just
track what did you Kobe ins are going to
if they have if they went to a limit
I'll call that what's known as a bully
and sub differential so I can't define
that limiting point as this generalized
bull again sub differential somewhere so
the Jacobian and the Clarkes is just a
convex hull of this alright so I'm not
I'm defining derivatives if you will for
non smooth locally Lipchitz doesn't mean
smooth for non smooth vector valued
functions but I just can't be completely
non smooth I still need a little bit of
structure in order to be able to run
through these Newton type stuff I want
them to be semi smooth now what a semi
smooth mean I want it to be locally
locally Lipchitz just because I can
define the generalized Jacobian I want
it to be directionally differentiable so
this ghetto differentiable so that's a
weaker notion of differentiability and
finally I wanted to have this sort of a
local linear approximation but this is
different that the what we know of you
know the fresh air differentiability
where your journey doesn't depend on on
the direction that you're looking at
here your j actually depends on that and
in fact belongs to this whole set of
clocks Jacobian but the idea of this is
that at least locally you can somehow
write this function as a linear function
right even though it's not the typical
linear stuff we were familiar with but
still you can still write it as some
kind of a linear approximation and you
can show that problem cases such as
piece piecewise continuous functions
conducive differential functions
actually satisfy this stuff so idea is
that all right I need to find the
solution of this linear system it's non
smooth or semi smooth and I can run
through
semi-smooth stop algorithms they get
pretty nasty they're not really easy to
work with as you can see there's a whole
lot of stuff that if you look at it
closely just mimics the a lot of the
stuff we do in a smooth case plus a
whole lot of caveats but they're
interesting stuff theoretically they are
wonderful but practically you know it's
it's hard to work with these sets right
how do you compute one of these or how
do you do it's not clear but they're
interesting stuff promising stuff to
work on and one thing that I'll leave
you with is that actually the reason why
a lot of these algorithms are
interesting at least to me are that
these proximal mappings we saw even
though they look crazy but they're set
of sub differentials with generalized
sub differentials they have they meet
the elements of their a positive
semi-definite so even though they are
crazy-looking and you know you wouldn't
look at them and appear we know that
there is a structure in fact the
elements of those general Jacoby ins are
positive semi-definite not all the
iterations I'll lend themselves to that
but a lot of the proximal mappings have
have that so I think I actually ended up
right on time because we started five
minutes late and I gave a whole lot of
reference references in here so if you
have you know we want to look at more
details there is you know a whole lot of
references at the end but I'll stop and
then I'll pick up non-convex next
session
[Applause]
so I found this all very interesting but
I I I was having trouble because this is
a new area for me kind of understanding
when like when does it rise and my
function is smooth versus so semi-smooth
wink and I compute the Hessian as this
are these things you're going to talk
about in the second half okay so maybe
maybe give an overview of when do I need
this when should I use the proximal Shh
okay so maybe I wouldn't really be able
to talk a lot about these specific ways
of computing these things for the fact
that there's just not enough time to do
I'll be more than happy to you know go
over these things with you if you want
on one on one we can talk about all of
this but most often a lot of the
canonical examples are obvious you know
you have a logistic regression Plus and
then one so you already know that
logistic is smooth and the other one is
non smooth so now you can't choose right
do i do proximal iterations can I do
proximal newton yeah why not because
this R which is in l1 it's an easy
function that's our problems I actually
easily done in fact it's done with an
exact solution why not but now you have
something that's a little bit crazier
you know you might say well let me try
something else you are interested in
theory you might say oh I just want to
do semi-smooth type stuff even though
you might be able to do proximal stuff
so it's you know it's it's not as clear
but I'll be able to discuss these in
much more details with you if you want
also say it on princess kind of is it
right to think a proximal step is when
you have like a regularizer
perfect if you have a know smooth
regular is there but if you have a non
smooth regular is there most most
regulars is that we use actually you can
plug them in there and you can do
proximal Newton process yes so
we had constraints but I not sure I've
heard a lot about constraints so yeah as
i said i remove the constraints in a lot
of these slides because it just makes
things that's all i wanted to talk about
linear systems and that arises when you
don't have constraints but a lot of
these like the global and local
converges results that I give that
pretty much go through even if this
constrains but you don't have linear
systems to talk about interesting so yes
so for the venue have a constrained
quadratic problem for that for example
you can use if you have a strongly
convex problem something like a Vista
you know fast iterative software does
well if it's non smooth but you can what
you call it like didn't accelerate it
gradient descent for example to solve
the quadratic sub problem well depends
on the constraint right if the
constraint is a quadratic right you can
do for example interior point methods I
don't know depends on the depends on the
constraint but if it's an arbitrary
constraint then maybe it's easier to and
it's easy to project on it maybe you can
do sort of like a great project a
gradient or whatever to salsa so they
totally depend on the constraint which
side do you take the limit do you need
to take because you need to be somehow
consistent let me think about two
different projects you go from upper so
if you look at the you're totally
talking about the directional derivative
yes so you actually go from so do you so
you have the you set a direction and you
go you send the the scalar to go to zero
formal doesn't matter this just because
it's part of the definition of this I've
never actually haven't seen it as part
of the analysis of the algorithm itself
it's the definition of the semi
smoothness if you have that and most
often these things you can show
something stronger that you know gives
you these results anyways
[Music]
do you assume that I don't know B is
easily decomposable or easily invertible
I'm asking because like the type of
problem that you right there as proxy
something is an optimization problem in
itself very very very if you do
something like sure sure
swish the quadratic sure but there most
often what what did that mean hole okay
so let me the Hessian in let's say for
example here this B is an arbitrary B I
mean it doesn't come from any anything
you put it in there you want to make
this iteration as general as possible
depending on some problem you might find
a B that works here nicely right so you
can set it to be a dying over you can
invert it easy right in a lot of cases
you have an option to compute for
example a quasi Newton which I'll talk
about next session quasi Newton type
matrices that you can iteratively update
the inverse of them already so you're
already given some matrix that you can
work with I talked in broad sense but
you're right there's a whole lot of
stuff you have to think about you can't
just plug in any matrix because it might
be harder to solve that than the
original problem and that's why I said
second order stuff got a lot more moving
parts you know it's it's not just the
gradient
let's take part again
[Applause]